[Musique]
l'année 2010 est de l'équipe de france
de football passe par une semaine sous
le soleil réunionnais et pour les voir
s'entraîner ils sont venus de toute
l'île ça vaut la peine parce que ça
montre un autre visage de la femme forte
qui peut faire le foot il peut faire
tous de sainte anne
les filles sont ils méritent autant que
les garçons sur les terrains il faut les
voir et on voit pas vraiment des grandes
différences à part l'aspect physique
mais les filles elles sont aussi allés
bon là où les prélats 23 joueuses
professionnelles et 12 encadrants qui
sont classés troisièmes sur le plan
mondial et dès l'échauffement ça se voit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les tribunes les fans du foot
féminin n'en perdent pas une miette
ouais et parce que enfin côté les hommes
sont trop suivi mais les femmes aussi
faudrait que voix c'est pareil on sait
juste que les hommes du coup un peu plus
vite et au plus de force plus de frappes
menées les femmes sont plus
intelligentes
qu'est ce que vous faites écouter j
c'est bien de jouer mes apps aussi de
bien de regarder comment ben ils sont
professionnels et aux lecteurs nature
localement plus de 2000 femmes
pratiquent le football en club avec un
championnat l'élite animé par 24 équipes
ce déplacement soutenue par le conseil
départemental ne peut être que bénéfique
selon les cadres de la ligue la pratique
féminine est un jeu dire en pleine
ascension
non c'est bien parce que ça reste un
match international on reçoit quand même
l'afrique du sud donc c'est important
aussi dans notre partenariat je dirais
avec la paf donc la confédération
africaine de football
et puis c'est la qualité du jeu aussi
bas c'est à dire que la com vous avez
comme vous pouvez voir à l'entraînement
on voit que la pratique féminine n'a
rien à envier du mois l'équipe de france
n'a rien à envier aux garçons
c'est assez plaisant regarder que ce
soit au niveau technique tactique et
même physique un entraînement engagé qui
fait quelques dégâts sous une pluie
d'été notre il offre ainsi ce qu'il y a
de meilleur à ses athlètes de haut
niveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deuxième jour ici on a une petite demi
heure pour aller mettre et les jambes
dans l'eau seulement mais j'espère qu'on
aura le temps de profiter un petit peu
avant de partir l'équipe de france
ramène du monde savait quand on joue en
france à la maison à chaque fois y'a du
monde est ok mais même ici a dit me sens
bien on est bien sûr je pense que les
garçons c'est pas possible de faire ça
aussi donc oui on est assez proches de
nos supporters et ça fait du bien oui
forcément on en prend du plaisir et déjà
parce que la réunion fait de bonnes
conditions pour ceux qui postent bah oui
c'est du cliché règne on avait un idéal
bientôt il a tout ce qu'il faut pour en
appréciant sans perdre une minute ces
professionnels se faufile dans le bus
chaque instant est chronométré afin de
faire de ce stage réunionnais un
tremplin sur la route de l'euro
[Musique]